hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the seven second
challenge this time with Aaron Brian man
left for game grumps he's from game
grumps and also eager after and also a
bunch of things that you probably see
okay describe in the name your ultimate
sandwich go me yeah go Oh bacon turkey
mayonnaise all right that's it
that doesn't she's maybe the challenge
you really can't lose the sandwich
sandwich so I say it and then to go yeah
okay name five Simpsons characters Bart
Lisa Marge Homer moment alright nailed
it we nailed it yes all right Ryan
suggest a blog username for an email kid
in 2005 go all that 96 you know what I
forgot the little after all that thing
did you just say do impressions of four
musical instruments in named Vanko
trumpet fanfare to befall for fake
clarinet who will it do to the flute I
could be a band I know these things make
up a reason for the extinction of
unicorn skill meteors magical meteors
what makes it magical it's just a
rainbow trail of money yeah get a
complaint magic that's always magic
okay I'm sorry it was my head my god I
never knew convince aliens not to
destroy the earth guys please please
please don't destroy the earth there's a
lot of cool things there I really like
it like wait anymore was born Oh
Oh make up a tongue-twister about
tomatoes Tomatoes talk to tacos okay
then you have a five-second so we have
to test with tomatoes Tomatoes Tomatoes
dr. Tucker with tomato stuff the peppers
and easy we just have to talk to me to
talk to dr. Tomatoes yeah if I can do
that it's not a tongue twister Oh
reenact a scene from The Lion King
oh no dominion of easy oh that's not
what he was holding up though it's the
circle of life tell a romantic story
about a dog in a cactus go the dog ate
the cactus the dog said oh that gave me
shivers to get off Adam it'll feel like
the shivers of romance yeah or the
shivers of these spines piercing his
intestines it will all give up its its
illusion Jersey you ready yeah Nate say
three things that run with clock talk
doc block nice day yeah for some of you
money out the back okay here we go maybe
I'll shave it in our heads yes
dr. Scott Irene tell an inspiring story
about me you have an inspiring story
about a goat in the Sun okay there was a
goat and he wanted to climb the hill to
see his love the Sun because the hill
always blocked it one day he finally
reached the top and kissed the Sun but
he died you okay
god damn I'm already crying on the
inside on the outside of emojis yeah
that's just telling him you're a
storyteller and I like it was that good
what should I write books
you should write like tiny posted
employs Oh recite a poem about a
disappointing milkshake this milk chick
is bad I am full of sad I have nothing
left in the world
I am so bad that belongs hung in a
twenty verb
else already crawling all of our
accomplishments are gonna get on you
audience tear straight in the camera and
laugh for seven seconds while pulling a
straight face stop my god no one's seen
that from the side there goes scary name
seven touch' fruit apple banana orange
peach mango cherry grape cherries are
buried Oh peach pear [ __ ] that very goof
don't look at me either
all right there's more things in this
room you can look at the cameras yes
name three means go
Doge the troll face and the the bad luck
Brian dude he just mean us make up a new
title for a Harry Potter book go Harry
Potter and the uncircumcised penis that
wouldn't be a real book wooden mark
we're going on oh sorry uh Harry Potter
and the the uncircumcised penis
whatever okay whatever you got it I
can't thank you can like comment and
subscribe
you agreed Harry Potter in the oven
circumcised feed oh you know more people
would read it than like Harry Potter and
mr. Koo koi yeah explain how you would
preferably like the universe to end go
uh with me with my dick inside of
something warm and gooey oh man I'll be
here for you too unibrow and I got you
[ __ ] about oh come on my tree the cause
of the end of the universe
suck a stinking over due to irritation
brother you know I don't even care
either way because I got my Dickens of
the Mormon GUI
maybe uh maybe we'll leave that to the
guy come on shoot dude wouldn't guys
wait Aaron Aaron wait I'm sorry Aaron oh
I like your joke I was I'm hearing oh my
second home oh hey no you're just doing
Thank You option
oh thank these guys - yeah oh yeah
so goo gah boom ah check out their
channels without bats that comes off